THOSE THEY ARE FOR THOSE.
IN FACT THEY ARE ROLE MODELS
IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T FIGURED
IT OUT.
DAVID TAFURI A LAWYER AND
FORMER ADVISOR TO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND JOINS US
TONIGHT OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER WHEN IT WAS THE
PARTY OF PEACE AND NOW THE
PARTY OF MANDATORY WAR.
I'M JUST WONDERING WHY
SHOULDN'T WE HAVE A DEBATE
ABOUT ARTICLE 5 IN NATO
WHICH OBLIGATES THE UNITED
STATES AND ALL MEMBERS OF
NATO TO DEFEND THE INTEREST
OF OTHER STATES?
SO WHY WOULD -- SHOULD WOULD
HE BE ON THE HOOK TORT FAIR
TOLER INTEGRITY OF ESTONIA
AND LATVIA.
>> THERE IS NOTHING WRONG TO
HAVE A DEBATE I HOPE IT WILL
BE EDUCATIONAL.
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT NATO
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN THE
PAST.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> MILITARY AND
INTELLIGENCE-SHARING
ALLIANCE AND ALSO AN
ALLIANCE OF LIKE-MINDED
COUNTRIES.
YOU ADMITTED THAT IN YOUR
OPENING THAT NATO WAS
SUCCESSFUL.
>> Tucker: IT IS.
I WOULD CELEBRATE IT.
>> NOW, NATO IS STILL
NEEDED.
HISTORY REPEATS ITSELF.
PUTIN'S RUSSIA IS KNOT THE
SAME AS THE SOVIET UNION BUT
IT'S TRYING TO DO SOME OF
THE SAME THINGS.
IT'S TRYING TO STAMP OUT
RULE OF LAUGH.
IT DOESN'T BELIEVE IN
FREEDOM.
IT DOESN'T BELIEVE IN FREE
MARKETS.
IT'S TRYING TO SPREAD A
VISION OF AUTOCRACY THAT
WILL ENRICH PUTIN AND OTHER
OLIGARCHS THAT'S WHAT THEY
HAVE IN RUSSIA AND TRYING TO
SPREAD IT TO THE REST OF
EUROPE.
>> Tucker: HOW IS THAT
DIFFERENT THAN CHINA ONLY
THAT IT IS LESS EFFECTIVE.
I DON'T THINK RUSSIA HAS
TAKEN OVER AFRICA OR LATIN
AMERICA YET OR THE CARIBBEAN
CHINA HAS.
IT'S ONLY FINE TO GET RICH
FROM SUCKING OFF THE CHINESE
OLIGARCHS OUR WHOLE ROLLING
CLASS DOES.
IT'S WRONG NOT TO DEFEND
LATVIA AGAINST PUTIN BECAUSE
WHY?
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> Tucker: I KNOW I AM.
>> NATO IS AN ALLIANCE
ALIGNED AGAINST CHINA IN
MANY WAYS AS WELL.
>> Tucker: NO LET'S --
>> -- COMPARING RUSSIA TO
CHINA DOESN'T MAKE RUSSIA
OKAY.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE TRYING TO
EXPLAIN WHY IT'S IN
AMERICA'S VITAL INTEREST TO
START A NUCLEAR WAR TO
DEFEND LATVIA.
>> NO, I DID NOT SAY THAT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S WHAT WE
WOULD BE OBLIGATED TO DO.
>> AMERICA'S VIOLATE
INTEREST TO DEFEND OTHER DID
YOU KNOW TRIES AROUND THE
WORLD THAT HAVE TRYING TO
BECOME DEMOCRACIES THAT ARE
TRYING TO PROMOTE FREEDOM
AND INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS AND
TRYING TO PROMOTE HUMAN
RIGHTS AND RULE OF LAW.
THAT'S WHAT LATVIA AT OTHER
BATH BALTIC STATES ARE DOING
AND WE SHOULD ENCOURAGE THAT
BY EXTENDING THAT SECURITY
UMBRELLA TO THEM.
>> Tucker: SO, IN OTHER
WORDS, OUR KIDS GET TO DIE
FOR LATVIA BECAUSE IT
SOMEHOW PROTECTS THE RULE OF
LAW FOR THEM TO TOO THAT.
I'M ASKING DOES THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN UNDERSTAND WE ARE
ON THE HOOK FOR THIS?
I THINK THAT'S A REAL
QUESTION WHICH IS TRYING TO
BE IGNORED.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SHUT DOWN
THE CONVERSATION.
>> YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
HISTORY.
IF LATVIA AND THE OTHER
BALTIC STATES FALL TO
AGGRESSIVE RUSSIA.
ULTIMATELY OTHER COUNTRIES
IN EUROPE AND ULTIMATELY IT
WILL COME BACK TO US ANYWAY
JUST LIKE WORLD WAR II.
THESE ARE THE SAME ARGUMENTS
PEOPLE MADE IN FAVOR OF NOT
DOING ANYTHING AGAINST
GERMANY AND NAZIS IN BOLDER
WAR 2.
THE EXACT SAME THING.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT ACTUALLY
MAKING THAT ARGUMENT.
>> YES, YOU ARE.
>> Tucker: NAZIS DO NOT
EXIST AND NEITHER DOES THE
SOVIET UNION.
I'M MAKING THE ARGUMENT IN
2019 WHICH WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
I'M INTERESTED SINCE YOU
BROUGHT IT UP WHAT EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES YOU THINK AT RISK
OF BEING INVADED BY RUSSIA?
>> CERTAINLY THE COUNTRIES
THAT HAVE RECENTLY JOINED
NATO.
THE BALTIC STATES ARE A
THREAT.
THAT'S WHY YOU BRUIT THEM
UP.
COUNTRIES NOT YET PART OF
NATO.
OTHER COUNTRIES NOT YET PART
OF NATO.
>> WESTERN EUROPE?
>> UKRAINE IS NOT PASSIONATE
OF NATO YET.
>> Tucker: PART OF THE
SOVIET UNION WHEN I GOT 20
MINUTES AGO.
>> THEY WANT TO BE FREE AND
NOW IT IS FREE.
>> Tucker: LOTS OF PEOPLE
WANT TO BE FREE.
POOR COUNTRY OF WESTERN
EUROPE.
>> POLL LAND.
>> Tucker: POLL LAND IS NOT
A CORE COUNTRIFULLY WESTERN
EUROPE.
>> YOU ARE WILLING TO
RECEIVED ALL OF EASTERN
EUROPE EVEN COUNTRY LIKE
POLAND.
ONLY PROTECT WESTERN EUROPE?
BECAUSE ONCE EASTERN EUROPE
GOES THEN WESTERN EUROPE IS
THREATENED.
>> Tucker: WE'RE ALMOST
DONE.
YOU THINK THERE IS A
PLAUSIBLE THREAT WITHIN OUR
LIFETIMES OF, SAY, THE U.K.,
GERMANY, BELGIUM, LITTEN
STEIN, SWITZERLAND, SPAIN,
PORTUGAL BEING INVADED BY
RUSSIA.
>> I'M THOUGHT SAYING THAT
ALL THE OTHER COUNTRIES IN
YEARN EUROPE INCLUDING THE
ONES WHO JOINED NATO FELL OF
COURSE THE NEXT FRONTIER FOR
RUSSIAN EXPANSIONISM WOULD
BE WESTERN EUROPE.
THAT'S OBVIOUS, I THINK.